Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. This is the second part of a two-part series on the history of Silicon Valley, the development of the internet, the role it plays in the kind of broadest historical spectrum, and we're incredibly privileged to have as our guest, absolute titan of the internet, Mark Andreessen, developer of the web browser, one of the profoundest thinkers and investors in this field. And the first billionaire to have ever appeared on The Rest Is History. Yes, Dominic, you're obsessed with.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。这是关于硅谷历史、互联网发展及其在更广泛历史光谱中所扮演角色的两集系列的第二集。我们非常荣幸地邀请到了互联网界的泰坦——马克·安德森作为我们的嘉宾。他是网页浏览器的开发者，也是该领域最具深刻洞察的思想家和投资人之一，同时也是首位登上《历史的余烬》的亿万富翁。是的，多米尼克，你对……
I am. I am. I'm above that. I've never spoken to somebody who's, I mean, just so colossally rich. But also such a, I mean, he'll be remembered when, you know, the man who popularised the web browser is much more important than any number of prime ministers. I'm not denying that, but I'm just above worrying about wealth. I know.
我是。我是。我才不在乎这个呢。我从来没跟这样的人交谈过，我是说，他简直富得流油。但他同时也是一个……我是说，当人们记住他时，你知道的，普及网页浏览器的人比任何数量的首相都要重要得多。我并不否认这一点，我只是不在乎财富罢了。我懂的。
A nobler and better person than you. I know, listeners. What what an utter utter lie that is let's let's move on um so in the previous episode we were um we were discussing social media yes we just come to it hadn't we we've come to that so facebook has has basically been invented um mark andreessen is on the board of facebook today. So he's an investor in Twitter, all kinds of things like that as well. So a guy who knows infinitely more about it. No one knows more about Twitter than you, Tom. I mean, you tweet more than about the rest of the population put together, don't you?
一个比你更高尚、更好的人。我懂的，听众朋友们。这真是彻头彻尾、百分之百的谎言啊。我们……我们继续吧。嗯，所以在上一集里，我们……我们讨论了社交媒体，对吧？我们刚刚切入这个话题，不是吗？我们聊到了这里——所以Facebook基本上已经被发明出来了——马克·安德森目前是Facebook的董事会成员。所以他也是Twitter的投资者，以及诸如此类各种事物的投资者。所以，他是一个对这方面了解无限多的人。没有人比你更了解Twitter了，汤姆。我的意思是，你发推文的频率比其余所有人口加起来还要多，对吧？
You and the other Tom Holland. Yeah, but I'm the user. He's the supplier. Right. Yeah. And it's the supplier knows yeah and it's the supplier you know nothing makes my day more than when you get birthday wishes or it is a tweet asking for an autograph or something from a teenage girl in tuscaloosa because i know how much it annoys you i always enjoy it it's hilarious um the one thing
你和另一个汤姆·霍兰德。对，但我只是个用户。他是供应商。没错。对。而且供应商知道……对，而且供应商……你知道的，最高兴的莫过于当你在塔斯卡卢萨收到一个十几岁女孩的生日祝福，或者是一条索要签名的推文的时候，因为我知道这有多烦你，我总是觉得这很有趣，太搞笑了。嗯，有一件事
that really annoys me is people who think that i've never heard a joke about my name being the same name as the guy who plays spider-man yeah that's the great thing about it you see that's the joke that never stops giving because it was quite i mean it was quite funny in kind of 47 ad right we've got mark andreessen or we had mark andreessen rather we spoke to him and we should bring him on shouldn't we we should just stop wittering to each other. We started by asking Mark about what I see as a tension at the heart of social media. So on the one hand, social media is supposed to be a great collective endeavour, bringing people together and uniting people across the world. This is part of Facebook's entire ethos, of course. But at the same time, it's something that you do on your own. And there's
真的让我很烦，那就是那些认为我从来没有听过关于我和那个扮演蜘蛛侠的家伙同名的笑话的人。是的，这正是它的绝妙之处，你看，这就是那个百听不厌的笑话，因为在大约公元47年的时候，它其实……挺好笑的。好吧，我们请来了马克·安德森，或者说我们之前请过马克·安德森，我们跟他聊过了，我们应该把他请上节目，对吧？我们不应该在这里自顾自地唠叨个不停。我们一开始问了马克一个问题，关于我所看到的社交媒体核心处的张力。一方面，社交媒体本应是一项伟大的集体事业，将世界各地的人们聚集并联合起来。当然，这是Facebook整个企业精神的一部分。但与此同时，这是一件你独自一人做的事。而且，
always a tendency to kind of retreat, as I see it, into silos or bubbles of like-minded people and to kind of screen out the rest of the world. So we asked him about that and whether he thinks that social media really does bring the world together. Well, so, you know, let's take on the sort of filter bubble or the silo thing right up front. And I know you guys, I listened to your Coffeehouse podcast last night, and you guys talked about this a little bit. But, you know, there has been this criticism of the internet um kind of the whole time and and i think there by the way there is some truth to it right and the criticism is this kind of they call the filter bubble criticism which basically is the internet lets you good news bad news the internet lets you find people
在我看来，人们总是有一种倾向，想要退缩到志同道合者的群体或泡沫中，并将世界其他地方屏蔽在外。所以我们问了他关于这一点，以及他是否认为社交媒体真的能将世界连结在一起。好吧，所以，你知道的，让我们开门见山地谈谈这种所谓的“过滤泡”或“信息茧房”现象。我知道你们俩，我昨晚听了你们的《咖啡馆播客》（Coffeehouse podcast），你们稍微讨论了一下这个。但是，你知道的，互联网一直以来都受到这种批评，而且我认为，顺便说一句，这种批评在某种程度上是有道理的，对吧？这种批评被称为“过滤泡”批评，其核心基本上是：互联网让你——好消息，坏消息——互联网能让你找到那些
who are exactly like you right so the whatever thing you're into whatever you know hobby you have whatever interest you have whatever politics you have whatever hobby you have, whatever interests you have, whatever politics you have, whatever religion you have, like, it doesn't matter, you know, up until the internet, like, if you did not grow up around people who shared that interest, you didn't have anybody to talk to who shared that interest. And with the internet, all of a sudden, you can go find people who just happen to correspond exactly to your preconceptions. And that can be a really wonderful thing. And that can also be, you know, the argument goes a really terrible thing, right? Because, you know, echo chambers, you know, reinforces, you know, maybe this sort of cult like behavior, you know, that you do see. You know, I think there's a truth to that. But I
与你完全相同的人，对吧？所以无论你痴迷于什么事物，无论你有什么爱好，无论你有什么兴趣，无论你的政治立场如何，无论你有什么爱好，无论你有什么兴趣，无论你的政治立场如何，无论你信仰什么宗教，这都无所谓，你知道的，在互联网出现之前，如果你身边的成长环境中没有与你分享这种兴趣的人，你就找不到任何人来谈论这种共同的兴趣。而有了互联网，你突然就可以找到那些恰好与你的先入之见完全吻合的人。这可以是一件非常美妙的事情。但与此同时，按照这种论点，这也可能是一件非常糟糕的事情，对吧？因为，你知道的，回音室效应，你知道的，强化作用，你知道的，也许还有你确实能看到的这种类似邪教的行为。你知道，我认为这有一定道理。但我
think there's also another truth. And the research on filter bubbles actually has demonstrated this other truth. The other truth is the internet also makes it much more likely you're going to encounter people who disagree. Right? So like, a lot of people in real life, as we say, IRL in real life, a lot of people in real life, you know, and this is sort of let's say this is like characteristic, for example, of a lot of highly educated people. Right. A lot of highly educated people grew up in these college towns. Right. And their parents are like college professors or something or professionals of some kind. And they grew up in these sort of relatively kind of insulated environments where everybody around them is like highly educated and, you know, kind of middle class, upper middle class, and often from, you know, a relatively narrow, you know, kind of selection of nationalities or ethnic groups. And, you know, and they basically in real life, they're only talking to people who are like themselves. And then, you know, and by the way, the same thing's true of rural America, the same thing's true of urban America, right? It's
认为还有另一个真相。关于“过滤泡”的研究实际上已经证明了这另一个真相。另一个真相是，互联网也大大增加了你遇到与你意见相左的人的可能性。对吧？所以，就像现实生活中的许多人一样，正如我们所说，IRL（在现实生活中），现实生活中的许多人，（这可以说是许多高学历人群的一个特征，对吧？许多高学历人群在这些大学城长大，对吧？他们的父母是大学教授或某种专业人士。他们在这种相对封闭的环境中长大，周围每个人都受过高等教育，你知道的，属于中产阶级、上中产阶级，而且通常来自相对狭隘的国籍或族群选择。）你知道，基本上在现实生活中，他们只和与自己相似的人交谈。然后，你知道的，顺便说一句，美国农村是这样，美国城市也是这样，对吧？
same thing's true of, you know, lots of places around the world. You know, people grew up in these kind of real world filter bubbles. And then you go on the internet and it's like you get slammed into this kaleidoscope of lots of people, lots of other things. And so all of a sudden, for the first time, you can, fragmented, you know, you know, superheated, you know, you know, tons of arguments. You know, why do people get sucked into arguing online? Right. You know, there's a famous cartoon, which is, you know, sorry, honey, I can't come to bed right now. Somebody is wrong on the Internet. Right. Like, why do people get sucked into arguing online? Right. Which has become kind of the national or the global hobby. It's because like there are people, you know, you just are slammed into running, you know, slammed into people's people who really don't agree with you. And so I think that that is the other side of it. development of the printing press, the growth of literacy, the ability of people to read stuff
世界上许多地方也是如此。人们在现实世界的“过滤泡”中长大。然后你上了互联网，就像被猛烈撞击进了一个万花筒，里面有形形色色的人和各种各样的事物。所以突然之间，你生平第一次，可以接触到碎片化的、你知道的、超级热烈的、各种各样的争论。为什么人们会被卷入网上的争论中？对吧？你知道，有一个著名的笑话是这样的：“对不起，亲爱的，我现在不能上床睡觉，网上有人错了。”对吧？为什么人们会被卷入网上的争论中？这已经成为一种全民或全球的爱好。那是因为有些人，你会被猛烈地撞击到——与那些根本不同意你观点的人发生碰撞。所以我觉得这才是硬币的另一面。印刷机的发明，识字率的增长，人们阅读
that previously they hadn't been able to read. I mean, you know, people then are able to kind of find people like them, but also they're able to find things that they really disagree with. And it has a transformative effect on the fabric and the culture of 17th, 18th century life do you think that um the internet is having a kind of analogous effect that it's amplifying the way in which people both agree and disagree with one another in ways that is kind of having a direct impact on politics in the u.s europe whatever yeah and in fact i think i would again, it took me a long time to come to grips with this, both because it's complicated
以前无法阅读的东西的能力。我的意思是，你知道，人们不仅能够找到与他们相似的人，而且他们还能够找到他们强烈反对的内容。这对17、18世纪生活的社会结构和文化产生了变革性的影响。你认为……互联网是否正在产生一种类似的影响，即它在放大人们彼此赞同和意见分歧的方式，并以某种对美国、欧洲等地的政治产生直接影响的方式发挥作用？是的，事实上我想再次说明，我花了很长时间才接受这一点，一方面是因为这很复杂，
and also because as a Midwesterner, it's hard for me to talk too dramatically about work I'm involved in. But I think it's hard to argue any other thesis than what you just stated. And I take it a step further, which is I think the internet brings a level of intensity to consuming information uh to communicating with
另一方面也是因为作为一个中西部人，我很难用过于戏剧化的语气来谈论我所参与的工作。但我认为，除了你刚才陈述的论点之外，很难再辩护其他观点。而且我还要更进一步，我认为互联网为信息的消费带来了某种强度，无论是与他人沟通、争论、成为运动的一部分、
other people to having arguments to being a part of a movement um you know to being a part of a scene uh to feeling like you're a part of history to feeling you know like you're you know fully connected to the kind of the flow of politics into cultural and social changes um the level of intensity the internet provides it seems to me is just way beyond, um, anything previous, right? Like, you know, you just like the, the rush of what happens when you get wrapped into these things online is just so far beyond the experience that, you know, you, you know, and it's, it's a striking right to kind of think about the history of, you know, can
成为某个圈子的一部分、感觉自己是历史的一部分、感觉自己（你知道的）完全融入了政治潮流以及文化和社会变革之中。互联网所提供的这种强度，在我看来，已经远远超出了以往的任何事物，对吧？就像你所经历的，当你被卷入这些网络事件时所受到的冲击，远远超出了你以前的经验。而且，（你知道的，）回想一下历史，这真的很引人注目，
you, if you guys can, can you visualize what it would have been like to be part of the first generation to learn how to read, um, and then, and then, you know, can you, if you guys can, can you visualize what it would have been like to be part of the first generation to learn how to read, and then, and then, you know, had access to a book, right, and, you know, and obviously people got, like, very enthusiastic about the Bible, right, like, you know, they went off on, you know, wars, and, like, all this stuff to follow, and so clearly they had, they had, they had this, you know, very high level of animating passion, but, like, you know, in, in our time, time, it's hard to imagine anybody getting that fired up about a book. But boy, are they getting fired up online. And so I think it's – right, I'll stop.
你们能不能，你们能不能想象一下，成为第一代学会阅读的人会是什么样的体验，然后，然后，你知道的，如果你能想象的话，想象一下成为第一代学会阅读的人，然后能够接触到一本书，对吧？显然，人们对《圣经》表现出了极大的热情，对吧？他们为了信仰大打出手，卷入了各种各样的战争。所以很显然，他们拥有这种非常高度的、激发他们热情的动力。但是，在我们的时代，很难想象会有人对一本书如此狂热。然而天哪，他们在网上却狂热得不得了。所以我想——好吧，我打住。
Sorry, if I can jump in, Mark. But to go back to combine the point you just made with Tom's previous point about the printing press. So in the first sort of decades after the invention of the printing press, you have this explosion of print culture and colossal consequences. I mean, the Protestant Reformation and so on. So the new technology goes hand in hand with an intensity that then drives political change. Do you think that the intense politics of the last, let's say, 10, 15 years.
对不起，马克，如果我能插话的话。但为了把你的观点和汤姆之前关于印刷机的观点结合起来。所以在印刷机发明后的最初几十年里，你看到了印刷文化的爆发和巨大的后果。我的意思是，宗教改革等等。所以新技术与一种强度齐头并进，而这种强度反过来推动了政治变革。你认为过去，比如说过去10年、15年里激烈的政治氛围……
So in America, the obvious example is the rise and fall of Donald Trump. I mean, that wouldn't have been possible without the internet, without social media, right? I mean, he used Twitter to communicate and his opponents used social media to kind of whip themselves into a frenzy of outrage at every new thing that he did. I mean, so the internet, it's not just that it creates a particular kind of politics, a very sort of assertive, maybe aggressive stride in politics, doesn't it? Well, so I sort of half agree. And the reason I half agree, of course, is because Trump is far from the first populist, right? Right.
所以在美国，最明显的例子就是唐纳德·特朗普的崛起与跌落。我的意思是，如果没有互联网，没有社交媒体，这是不可能发生的，对吧？我的意思是，他利用Twitter来沟通，而他的反对者则利用社交媒体在面对他的每一个新举措时，煽动自己陷入愤怒的狂热中。我的意思是，所以互联网，它不仅仅是催生了一种特定类型的政治，一种非常自信、也许甚至是咄咄逼人的政治姿态，不是吗？好吧，所以我对此持半信半疑的态度。我之所以半信半疑，当然是因为特朗普远不是第一个民粹主义者，对吧？
Agreed. Right. Because before Trump, you had, you know, when I was younger, Ross Perot almost won the presidency, right? He was a very Trump-like figure. Before that, obviously, you had Huey Law, when I was, you know, when I was, when I was younger, Ross Perot, like almost won the presidency. Right. He was very Trump, like figure, you know, before that, obviously you had, you know, Huey Long, right. William Jennings Bryant. And, and, you know, so, and then of course, you know, talking about populace, right. You know, you had, you know, your Hitlers and your Mussolini's right. It's, you know, everybody's like,
没错。没错。因为在特朗普之前，你有过——当我年轻的时候，罗斯·佩罗（Ross Perot）差点赢得总统大选，对吧？他是一个非常具有特朗普风格的人物。在此之前，很明显，你有过休伊·朗（Huey Long）。在我年轻的时候，罗斯·佩罗差点赢得总统大选。没错。他是一个非常具有特朗普风格的人物。你知道，在此之前，很显然，你有过休伊·朗，威廉·詹宁斯·布莱恩（William Jennings Bryan）。而且，你知道的，然后当然，说到民粹主义者，你知道，你有过希特勒和墨索里尼，对吧？每个人都觉得，
oh my God, the internet's responsible for the rise of fascism. Right. And it's, you know, in the modern world. And it's like, well, you know, we, I, you know, we actually had fascism like 70, 80 years ago. And you know that hitler fellow say what you will like he didn't have access to the internet so um you know somehow he figured out a way to do it with you know but he's always on the internet now isn't he he's always you guys know godwin's law there's actually a lot of the internet every every discussion inevitably becomes a discussion about Hitler. So, you know, so it's like, basically, it's like, there is no, you know, like, in a sense, there's nothing new, you know, kind of about the politics of our era. And I would even say that in maybe a set of a disappointing
“天哪，互联网要为法西斯的崛起负责。”在现代世界中，情况就是这样。然而事实上，我们其实在70、80年前就已经经历过法西斯主义了。你知道，那个叫希特勒的家伙——不管你怎么说他——他可没有互联网可用。所以，嗯，不知怎的，他还是找到了用这种方式做到这一点的办法……但他现在总是在互联网上，不是吗？他总是……你们知道戈德温法则（Godwin's law）吗？事实上，在互联网上有很多这样的情况：任何讨论最终都不可避免地演变成关于希特勒的讨论。所以，你知道，基本上这就好比，从某种意义上说，我们这个时代的政治并没有什么新鲜事。我甚至会以一种或许令人失望的方式来说明这一点，
way, which is, it feels at least to me, like, we're kind of rehashing, you know, kind of old and settled, you know, debates and arguments from, you know, whether 30 years ago or 70 years ago or 100 years ago. And so, so therefore, establishing causation is hard. And so I guess, I guess the way I would put it is like, I don't know that the internet, I don't think the internet, for sure, it didn't cause populism, or by the way, the same thing, right, the resurgence of this, you know, kind of, you know, kind of more, let's say, primal kind of leftism, you know, at the same time, which is sort of you can kind of see in both, you know, kind of wokeness on the one hand, but also kind of this re-rise of socialism, you know, on the other hand, right. So the corresponding kind of, you know, at the same time, which is sort of, you can kind of see in both, you know, kind of wokeness on the one hand, but also kind of this re-rise of socialism, you know, on the other hand, right? So the corresponding kind of, you know, thing is happening on the left. But again, there, it's like, you know, identity politics are not new
那就是，至少在我看来，我们似乎在老调重弹，在重新咀嚼那些陈旧的、已经尘埃落定的辩论和争论——无论是来自30年前、70年前还是100年前。因此，要确立因果关系是很困难的。所以我想，我倾向于这样表达：我不知道互联网——我不认为互联网绝对是导致民粹主义的原因，或者顺便说一句，同样的情况也适用于这种更加原始的左翼主义的同时复苏，这种复苏你既可以在一方面“觉醒文化”（wokeness）中看到，也可以在另一方面社会主义的再度崛起中看到。所以，左翼也正在发生与之相对应的现象。但同样，在这里，这也是一样的道理：身份政治并不是互联网时代的新产物。早在互联网出现之前的20世纪60年代，它就是一个大问题。当然，族裔和种族分裂也不是新鲜事，它非常古老。然后，你知道的，社会主义也不是新鲜事，对吧？而且，话说回来，社会主义——俄国革命——的发生是以什么为基础的？不就是靠油印机吗？嗯，还有，
with the internet. They were a big deal in the 1960s, pre the internet. And of course, ethnic and racial division is not new. It's very old. And then, you know, socialism is not new, right? And, you know, again, the socialism, you know, the Russian revolution, you know, happened on the basis of what, like the mimeograph machine. Um, so, um, and, you know, in-person organizing. So, so, you know, do these technologies create these things? I don't think so. Um, uh, on the other hand, I think there's a, at least my model is basically the technology
线下的人员组织。所以，你知道的，这些技术创造了这些事物吗？我不这么认为。另一方面，我认为——至少我的模型是这样的——当时的科技是这些事物的渠道。然后它充当了——你可以说是放大器，或者说是一种组织推动力。所以，如果说纳粹党是广播电台的结果，而俄国革命是油印机的结果，那么，这些都是非常原始的理念，但它们是通过那个时代的科技流淌传播的。而现在我们有了这种——好吧，然后你可以从反面来论证，那就是现在我们拥有了一种——我认为——更加深刻、或者说更具切身感受的技术形式，它比以往任何时候都更加深入人们的生活，比以前的技术更加强大。所以，这或许是旧的理念，但却以新的方式表达出来，并导致了不同的后果。顺便说一句，让我……让我补充另一个理论，对吧？那就是，每当发生——至少根据我对历史的理解——在互联网出现之前，如果你有一个基本的大规模政治运动，它的特征是街头活动，对吧？比如会有冲突、骚乱，你知道的，会有流血事件、有人丧生，会有大型的公众罢工、抗议以及所有这些事情。当然，我们——你知道的，
of the time is it's like, it's the conduit, uh, for these things. And then it's, you know, you might say the amplifier or, you know, the organizing, you know, kind of agent. And so, you know, if the Nazi party, for example, was the consequence of, you know, radio and the Russian revolution, it's consequence, mimeograph machines, like, you know, again, those are, those are very primal ideas, you know, but they flowed through the technology of that time. And now we have this, well, then you can argue the other side of that, which is now we have this sort of, I would argue, kind of much more, or I'd say even more visceral form of
从美国不时发生的街头活动中也能看到这一点。但还有另一种观点，基本上认为互联网是现实世界活动的一种替代品。因此，这里有一个更为温和的推论：也许互联网极大地煽动了政治情绪，让所有人都情绪高涨，但也许人们基本上都忙于在键盘上敲敲打打，而没有真正走到街上去。是的，不过当然，像“阿拉伯之春”这样的事件——我的意思是，这是一个很好的例子，证明了互联网确实把人们带到了街上，不是吗？我的意思是——是的，那是真的。事实上，压迫性政权从“阿拉伯之春”中吸取了教训，这也是他们在当今这些事情发生时所极力应对的局面：当网上出现大规模政治运动，甚至
technology that's even more present in people's lives, that's even more powerful than the ones that came before. And so maybe it's old ideas, but being expressed in new ways and leading to different consequences. By the way, let me let me add one other theory, right? Which is, you know, whenever you had, like, at least my understanding of history is like, you know, before the internet, if you had like that, basically a mass political movement, right, it was characterized by street activity, right? Like you have, you know, fights and riots, and you know, you'd have like, you know, bloodshed, people getting killed, you know, big public strikes and protests and all these things. And of course, you know, we, you know, fights and riots and, you know, you'd have like, you know, bloodshed, people getting killed, you know, public strikes and protests and all these things. And of course, you know, we, you know, we do have, you know, from time to time we have activity in the streets, you know, in the US.
现实世界的抗议活动也是在网上组织起来的时候，会发生什么？如果你是一个压迫性的政权，你脑海中浮现的第一件事就是：“我要掐断互联网，我要按下紧急切断开关。”当然，这绝对是把所有人逼上街头的最稳妥的方法。或者说，马克，我的意思是，看看塔利班，他们在Twitter上。你知道的，如果他们告诉我们他们喜欢的代词是什么，我也不会感到惊讶。我的意思是，他们在Twitter上，而唐纳德·ท特朗普却不在。从某种意义上说，也许……那些积极进取的极权主义者会使用社交媒体，并且精心雕琢他们的信息，对吧？你精心雕琢信息，你可以……是的，我的意思是，我看到……我前几天看到
But like, there's another argument basically, which is the internet is a substitution for real world activity. Right. And so there's a more benign kind of projection here, which is maybe the internet greatly inflames politics and gets everybody all heated up. But maybe people are basically too busy pounding away at their keyboards to go out into the streets. Yeah. Though, of course, something like the Arab Spring, I mean, that's a good example of something where the internet did get people out in the streets, didn't it? I mean – Yeah, that's right. And, in fact, one of the things that repressive political regimes learned from the Arab Spring and which they grapple with today when these things happen, which is, okay, what happens when there's like mass political movement online and where you even
塔利班希望你们知道，他们首选的代词是“他/他的”（he/him），我认为对此没有什么好怀疑的。所以互联网可以……好吧，然后还有另一个……还有另一个问题，从你刚才所说的话中衍生出来，基本上是：互联网在多大程度上实际上……是的，互联网可能在某种程度上推动了分裂等等。但也许互联网更广泛的影响在于，它是一台巨大的同化机器，对吧？它是一台将人们同化进广义上的西方文化的巨大同化机器，对吧？这就是约瑟夫·亨里奇（Joseph Henrich）那种“WEIRD”（西方、受过教育、工业化、富有、民主）的概念，也许互联网——这种概念，你知道的，也许互联网，也许。话说回来，如果你是一个传统主义者，你基本上会说，互联网基本上——如果你是一个传统主义者，你会说现代媒体和现代文化在过去的几十年甚至几个世纪里，一直都在把人们从他们的历史文化中剥离出来，这种现象已经持续很久了。但互联网将完成这个过程。
have real world protests being organized online? If you're a repressive political regime, the very first thing you think of is I'm going to shut off that internet, right? I'm going to kill the switch. And of course, that is the guaranteed way now to get everybody in the street. Or, Mark, I mean, looking at the Taliban, you know, they're on Twitter. And, you know, it wouldn't surprise me to, you know, they'll give us their preferred pronouns. I mean, they're on Twitter, whereas Donald Trump isn't. And in a sense, perhaps, you know, the go-getting totalitarian you you get on social media and you kind of uh you manicure your message right you manicure the message you could yeah i mean i saw me i saw me
就像互联网将把每一个孩子从他们无论怎样的本土文化中剥离出来一样。没错……而你知道的，你刚才提到了“觉醒文化”（wokeness），我们在这个播客里经常会顺便探讨一下觉醒文化。显然，在英国有一种观点认为，这里关于这种“觉醒”文化的大量争论，其实是我们本土文化的一种“美国化”过程。基本上是因为社交媒体上有太多人、太多意见领袖，他们看着美国发生的事情，然后直接照搬过来。你认为……我的意思是，你在多大程度上认为互联网——从某种程度上讲，因为你是
the other day as the taliban would like you to know that their preferred pronouns are he him don't think there's much doubt about that so that the internet could be well then there's this other well there's this other question right which flows from what you just said which is basically to what extent is the internet actually – yes, the internet may to some extent drive division and so forth. But maybe the sort of broader impact of the internet is that it's a giant assimilation machine, right? And it's a giant assimilation machine into Western culture broadly defined, right? And it's the Joseph Henrich kind of weird kind of concept, which is maybe the internet – you know, kind of concept, which is, you know, maybe the Internet, maybe. And again, this is sort of like if you were a traditionalist, you would basically say the Internet, basically, you know, basically, if you're a traditionalist, you'd say modern media and modern culture for the last whatever, you know, decades and centuries has always been ripping people out of their historical cultures, you know, for a long time now. But the Internet will complete that process.
一个中西部人，而且在所有这些事情上你都是最不适合被问及的人——但你在多大程度上认为互联网和社会……它们在多大程度上是美国化的巨大引擎？我想确实如此。而且这很容易听起来像是“凯旋主义”（triumphalist），这并不是我的本意。事实上，我认为这背后可能存在真正且重大的负面影响，但我认为有一个非常有力的论据可以支持这一点。好吧，看，这就跟人们对好莱坞长久以来的争论一模一样，对吧？
Like the Internet is just going to rip every kid out of whatever the local culture is well that's um and you know right that you mentioned um wokeness wokeness is that we often have a little have a little segue into discussions of wokeness in this podcast and obviously there's there's an argument in britain for example that a lot of the argument about the kind of woke culture here is an americanization of our own kind of national culture that basically because of so many people on social media so many opinion formers they look at what's happening in the states and they just import it do you think there's I mean to what extent do you think the internet I mean in some ways because you are
是的，那就是关于好莱坞的争论，比如克林特·伊斯特伍德（Clint Eastwood）曾经塑造了一种风靡全球的男子气概形象，对吧？所以在20世纪60、70年代，世界各地的孩子们都在说，“啊哈，这就是我想成为的样子，”对吧？所以，这是一个更古老的观点。但是，是的，互联网同样如此，它是如此直观，它以一种极其戏剧化的方式将你拉入其中，这是一种如此激烈的体验。其中包含一个语言层面的因素，即互联网上的内容绝大多数都是英文的。因此，这必然会巩固英语作为全球通用语的地位，你觉得呢？
a midwesterner and everything you're completely the wrong person to ask but to what extent is the kind of internet and social to what extent are they massive engines of americanization do you think so i think that's the case and this you know this this can easily sound triumphalist which is not kind of how i intended in fact i think there might be real significant you know downsides to this but i i think there's a very powerful argument to be made well look it's the same argument people have been making about hollywood forever right um yeah which is sort of you know you know clint east you know there's an argument used to be made about hollywood you know clint eastwood kind of defined a sort of image of
是的，绝对如此。顺便说一句，我告诉你们，我们现在经常看到一种以前没有见过的现象：那些从世界各地来到硅谷的、刚刚二十出头的全球新锐年轻企业家们，他们来到这里时，居然没有口语腔调。他们说的是完全流利的美式英语。我总是问：“你的英语是怎么练得这么好的？”然后他们看着我，露出一副疑惑的表情说：“YouTube啊。”对吧？
masculinity to like global, right? And so you've got kids, you know, all over the world in the 1960s, 1970s, were like, you know, aha, you know, it's, that's what I want to be like, right. And so, you know, this, this is an older idea. But yeah, the internet, again, it's just, it's so visceral. It pulls you in, like, so dramatically, It's such an intense experience. There's a language component to it, which is the internet is overwhelmingly English language. And so it must be entrenching the status of English as the global lingua franca, do you think? Yeah, absolutely. And by the way, I'll just tell you, here's a phenomenon we now routinely see, which we didn't see before. So the newly arrived entrepreneurs, the global entrepreneurs coming
没错。所以，是的，这里面有一个语言因素。显而易见，语言本身就是一种文化载体，正如法国人会告诉你的那样。然后，是的，然后还有所有其他的因素，所有其他将要发生的因素。我的意思是，不，其中有一些非常根本的事情，比如——你知道的——信息不受控制的流动这一基本理念，对吧？这正是互联网带来的特质，人们对此总是大惊小怪，但当然，这非常具有西方色彩，对吧？而且，非常具体地说，这是一种美国式的特质，将言论自由视为首要的事情。然后，是的，还有所有的这些态度。
from all over the world who come to Silicon Valley that are in their early twenties now, they show up here, they don't have accents. They speak completely fluent American English. And I always ask like, how did you get so good at English? And it's like, well, they said, you know, they look at me like I'm, you know, puzzled and they're like, YouTube, right? Like, yeah. Right. And so, yeah. So there's a language component, obviously, you know, language itself is a, it's a culture carrier as the French will tell you. And then yeah. And then there's just all of the other components, there's just all of the other components to go. I mean, no, there's the really fundamental things, which is just like, you know, the basic idea of uncontrolled
前一段时间，网上有一场辩论我觉得非常有趣。经济学家布莱恩·卡普兰（Bryan Caplan）基本上说，不要……他基本上把西方文明称为……他说，每个人都总是担心西方文明会被埋葬，或者……他说，这是一种他所谓的“顽强野草”（Hardy weed）。他基本上提出了这样一个论点：西方文明将会蔓延并吞噬一切。
flow of information, right. It's just, it's something that comes with the internet that, you know, that people are, you know, freak out about all the time, but like that of course is a very Western, you know, kind of thing. And, you know, it's very specifically like, you know, an American thing with freedom of speech as a sort of a primary thing. And then, yeah, there's, yeah, just all of, yeah, all of the attitudes. You know, there's this debate online a while ago that I found really interesting. So Brian Kaplan, the economist basically said, don't, you know, basically he called Western civilization, he said, everybody's always worried about kind of Western civilization getting buried. Or, um, and he said, it's, it's, he called it the Hardy weed. Um, and he basically made this argument that Western civilization is kind of going to spread
而斯科特·亚历山大（Scott Alexander）则基本上争辩说，这不是西方文明，而是普遍文明（universal civilization），因为基本上……基本上它是西方文明，但融合了其他人文化中最优秀的元素。对吧？举个例子，日本动漫已经在互联网上走向全球，对吧？这种现象就像是，日本动漫已经被纳入了西方对娱乐和媒体的理解之中，这是在互联网出现之前所没有的。所以，斯科特会说，这将是每个人的文化被揉合在一起的产物。对此最乐观的看法是，这将是每个人的文化被揉合在一起，并且包含了每个人文化中最精华的部分。这或许是最乌托邦的看法了。好吧，我们都很支持
and eat everything. And then Scott Alexander basically argued, it's not Western civilization, it's universal civilization because basically it's basically it's Western civilization, but incorporating all of the best elements of everybody else's culture. Right. And so just as an example, you know, Japanese anime has gone global on the internet. Right. And it's sort of like Japanese anime has been kind of embraced into kind of
乌托邦的看法，而且我认为……这实际上是一个进入中场休息的完美切入点。所以我们休息过后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest is Entertainment）。这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的专属节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将为娱乐界拉开帷幕，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、加更节目并优先获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
the Western conception of entertainment and media in a way that it wasn't before the internet. And so, so Scott would say, it's going to be everybody's culture kind of munched together. The positive view of this is going to be everybody's culture kind of munched together, including the best of everybody's culture. And that's maybe the most utopian view. Well, we're all in favor of
大家好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在讨论互联网作为世界历史上最伟大的革命力量之一。我们的嘉宾是马克·安德森。马克，你曾经写过一篇著名的文章——《软件正在吞噬世界》。我想，这其中几乎有点类似于马克思对资本主义的经典评价：一切坚固的东西都烟消云散了。软件似乎具有这种能够转化和吞噬一切传统、一切坚固事物的能力……你认为，用这种方式来描述互联网的影响是否合理？比如软件为我们带来了Netflix而不是百视达（Blockbuster），给我们带来了亚马逊而不是博德斯书店（Borders）。
utopian views and i think that um that would actually be a perfect note to go to a break um so we will see you back after the break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我认为这是真的。但除此之外，还有一个更深层次的东西，这也是我试图在最初那篇《软件正在吞噬世界》的文章中探讨的：从技术的镜头来看，互联网是软件的载体。我们现在对软件有点习以为常了，因为每个人都在使用软件，每个人都知道什么是应用程序，等等。所以软件是什么似乎是显而易见的，但是，软件背后隐藏着一个深刻的真理，我认为这个真理至今仍被低估了。基本上——这也是我小时候让我对所有这些东西产生兴趣的最初原因——软件是你在现实世界中所能接近“魔法”的极限。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. We are talking the internet as one of the great revolutionary forces in world history. And we are with Mark Andreessen, who, Mark, you wrote a famous essay, how software is eating the world. And I guess, I mean, there's almost something there perhaps of marx who said of capitalism you know famously that all that is solid melts into where the way that it kind of has this ability to transform and devour everything traditional everything solid um do you think is that a reasonable way to describe the impact of the Internet, the way that software has given us Netflix rather than Blockbuster? It's given us Amazon rather than Borders.
我经常具体使用“炼金术”的比喻，对吧？也就是说，软件……就像众所周知的炼金术一样，它是一场寻找某种东西的探索，无论那种神奇的公式叫什么。对吧？哲人石（Philosopher's stone）可以把一种富足的物质（铅）变成一种稀有且昂贵的物质（金子）。而软件，基本上就是把——字面意义上、真真切切地——在键盘上敲击键盘的行为，转化为现实世界中各种变化的“哲人石”。所以，世界上最容易的事情是什么？就是坐在那里敲键盘。
So I think that's true. But then there's also a deeper thing, which is what I tried to get to in the original software. It's the world essay, which is the internet is a viewed through a technological lens. The internet is a carrier of software. And we kind of take software a little bit for granted now because, you know, we, everybody uses software and everybody knows what an app is and so forth. And so it kind of seems like it's obvious what software is, but like, there's a, there's a deep truth to software, which I think maybe is still, still underestimated, which basically, and this is kind of what got me interested in all this stuff when I was a kid to start with, is software is like as close to magic as you can get in the real world.
而世界上最难的事情是什么？——等等，世界上最难的事情是选举一位新总统、建立一个全球性的新企业、说服所有这些汽车突然开始接载乘客、或者说服人们敞开家门让别人借宿？（提到了Uber和Airbnb）或者，顺便说一句，甚至是利用软件让每个人意识到他们的朋友都在网上并保持着连接，他们可以通过Facebook的形式与所有朋友交谈。所以，基本上在所有这些事情中，每当软件被用来做任何事情时，总有人坐到键盘前，有人在输入这些神奇的咒语——用这种奇怪的巫术语言。然后，在某个时刻，他们按下回车键。
And I often specifically use the metaphor of alchemy, right? Which is software, you know, it's like famously with alchemy, it was a search for whatever it was called, whatever the magic formula that was used. Right. Philosopher's stone that would turn something that was abundant, lead, into something that was rare and valuable, gold. Well, software basically is the philosopher's stone for turning literally, quite literally typing on a keyboard into changes in the real world. So what's the easiest thing in the world to do is to sit and type on a keyboard?
然后，现实世界就改变了。事情发生了变化。汽车开始自动驾驶了。对吧？你知道的，现实世界中确实发生了真正令人惊叹的变化。所以这是一个……这是一个……这是一个杠杆，对吧？这是一个……基本上，这是一个巨大的杠杆。如果你想在现实世界中改变某些东西，现在最简单、最强大的方法就是编写软件。我会说，这个事实——你知道的，这是我基本上一生的主导事实，也是我作为风险投资家的整个职业生涯的主导事实，这就是我们所有的公司所做的事情。你知道，基本上，
And what's the hardest thing in the world to do is to sit and type on a keyboard? And what's the hardest thing in the world to do is elect a new president or create a new global business or convince all these cars to all of a sudden be picking up riders or convince people to open up their homes and take in people to be able to stay in their homes? References to Uber and Airbnb. Or, by the way, even software to get everybody to realize that their friends are all online and connected and they can talk to all their friends in the form of Facebook. And so it's basically like in every one of these things, every time software is used to do anything, somebody has set up a keyboard, somebody has typed in these sort of magical incantations in this kind of weird sorcery language. And then at some point, they press enter.
世界上几乎所有最优秀的创业青年现在都有动力去创办这种企业，去做这种事情。你知道吗？所以，这很可能仍然是一个被大大低估的因素。很多人仍然把软件视为一种独立的计算机事物，但它现在已经不是那样了。在这一点上，它已经编织进了解现实的基本面里。对吧？
And then the real world changes. Things change. The car starts to drive itself. Right. You know, really, really amazing changes actually happen in the real world. And so it's this it's this it's this lever. Right. It's this it's this basically it's this, you know, it's this it's this giant lever where if you want to change something in the real world, like the easiest and most powerful way to do it. Now it's to write software. And I would say like that, that fact is like, you know, that's the dominant fact of my basic entire life, but you know, my entire career as a venture capitalist, this is what all of our companies do. You know, all of, you know, basically, you know,
但这会带来后果，无论是好是坏，对吧？我的意思是，如果我现在结束这段谈话，走出门去，五分钟后我就会走到高街（High Street），也就是你们所说的美式主街（Main Street）。那里到处都是……比方说，高街，也就是我们所说的主街，上面有许多空置的店面。而且，你知道的，放眼世界，如果这场革命加速，如果人工智能产生了人们预期的那种影响，那将会引发巨大的政治……那将带来巨大的政治和经济挑战，不是吗？不仅对我们如此，对我们的继承者以及他们的继承者等等都是如此。好吧，毫无疑问，将会发生巨大的变革。
almost all of the really great entrepreneurial kids in the world now are motivated to start this kind of business, to do this kind of thing. You know? And so this, this, this is probably still a greatly, this is still a greatly underestimated factor. It's like software is sort of still visualized by a lot of people as like a separate computer thing. And it's really not that anymore. It's like woven into basically all of reality at this point. Yeah.
毫无疑问。你知道的，在这些对话的这个阶段，你经常会听到某种反乌托邦式的经济预测，人们会……经典的说法是：“新技术将导致大规模失业。”对吧？因为如果我们有软件来做所有这些事情，那人们要做什么呢？如果你戴上经济学家的帽子，你基本上会说，情况并非如此。对吧？之所以不会这样，是因为技术永远不会导致大规模失业。当然，原因在于技术所代表的是生产力的提高，对吧？从经济学角度来说。对吧？
But that has consequences, I mean, for good and ill, right? I mean, if I terminate this conversation now and go and walk down the street, in five minutes I'll be in High Street, what you would call Main Street. And it's full of, let's say, High Street, what we would call Main Street. And it's full of, let's say, storefronts that are unoccupied. And there are, I mean, around the world, if this revolution speeds up and if AI has the effect that people think it will, that's going to cause colossal political and that's going to pose these immense political and economic challenges, isn't it? Not just for us, but for our successors and for their successors and so on. Well, some massive change, for sure.
技术是一种“以少做多”的方式。当你以少做多时，你就增加了社会财富，对吧？随着社会财富的增加，你实际上增加了消费者需求。你增加了消费者的购买力，对吧？你字面意义上创造了新的需求。你为人们支付和负担事物创造了新的能力。然后，你知道的，新的产业、新的领域、新的活动就会被创造出来。
You know, no question. You know, you often at this point in these conversations, you get to like these sort of dystopian, you know, kind of economic projections where people, you know, kind of, you know, the classic one is, well, you know, new technology will lead to mass unemployment. Right. Because if we have software doing all these things, then what will the people do? You know, if you put your economist hat on, you basically say that's not what happens. Right. And the reason that's not what happens, technology never leads to mass unemployment. And the reason, of course, is because what technology represents is increase in productivity. Right. In economic terms. Right.
你知道的，毫无疑问。你知道的，在这些对话的这个阶段，你经常会接触到那种反乌托邦式的、某种经济预测，人们会觉得，你知道的，最经典的说法就是，新技术会导致大规模失业。对吧。因为如果我们有软件来做所有这些事情，那人们要做什么呢？你知道的，如果你戴上经济学家的帽子，你基本上会说事情不会那样发展。对吧。事情不会那样的原因，技术从来不会导致大规模失业。当然，原因在于技术代表的是生产力的提高。对吧。用经济学术语来说。对吧。
Technology is a way to do more with less. When you do more with less, you increase societal wealth, right? As you increase societal wealth, you actually increase consumer demand. You increase consumer spending power, right? You quite literally create new demand. You create new ability for people to be able to pay for and afford things. And then, you know, new industries, new fields, new activities get created
技术是一种以更少资源做更多事情的方式。当你用更少做更多时，你增加了社会财富，对吧？随着社会财富的增加，你实际上增加了消费需求。你增加了消费者的消费能力，对吧？你简直是在创造新的需求。你为人们支付和负担得起东西创造了新的能力。然后，你知道的，新的产业、新的领域、新的活动就被创造出来了
that ends up soaking up all the, you know, all the labor. Do you think the experience of the pandemic has been an illustration of that? That the economic devastation has been much less than people thought it would be yeah well there were two parts so there were two parts to this that's so striking and so basically so yeah so two things so one is you know basically from like 2010 to 2019 at least the american press was absolutely full of i would say what right what i you know theories it was all this it was this just non-stop drumbeat of like the Internet's going to destroy all the jobs and robots are going to be whatever.
最终承担了所有，你知道，所有的劳动力。你觉得大流行的经历说明了这一点吗？经济破坏远比人们想象的要小，是的，有两部分，所以这有两部分，太惊人了，基本上，所以，是的，所以两件事，一个是，你知道，基本上从2010年到2019年左右，至少美国媒体到处充斥着，我会说，对吧，我所知道的理论，它全是这个，这是这种不间断的鼓点，就像互联网将摧毁所有的工作，机器人将无论如何。
And nobody's going to have anything to do. And it's going to be this dystopian, dystopian thing. And then basically what happened was up to March 2020, I'm sorry, up to January 2020, the American economy right after 250 years of like seriously, you know, onrushing technological change, including the full impact of Internet and software and all the stuff that was happening up until January 2020, right, resulted in the best consumer economy and the best employment economy in the history of the United States. Right. So in January of 2020, you know, unemployment in the U.S. was at all time lows. Unemployment among the lowest skilled educated in the U.S. was at all time lows. You know, incomes were at all time highs,time highs, job growth, wages actually were rising. As of January 2020, wages were rising faster for lower income people than they were for higher income people. So you were actually starting to get a reinvigoration of wage growth, which is what you get when you get a productivity boom.
而且没有人会有事可做。这将是一个反乌托邦的，反乌托邦的事情。然后基本上发生的事情是，直到2020年3月，对不起，直到2020年1月，美国经济在经历了250年严重的、你知道的、奔涌的技术变革之后，包括互联网和软件的全部影响以及直到2020年1月发生的所有事情，对吧，造就了美国历史上最好的消费经济和最好的就业经济。对。所以在2020年1月，你知道，美国的失业率处于历史最低点。美国技术和教育程度最低的人群中的失业率处于历史最低点。你知道，收入处于历史最高点，工作增长，工资实际上在上涨。截至2020年1月，低收入人群的工资增长速度快于高收入人群。所以你实际上开始重新焕发工资增长的活力，这就是当你获得生产力繁荣时所得到的。
And so it was quite literally the best economy we've had in maybe forever in January 2020. It was great. And then, of course, COVID arrives. right? And exactly to your point, like I was like, you know, like a lot of people, I just got totally freaked out by COVID early on. And in part was like, oh my God, we're going to voluntarily, you know, we're going to take basically the best economy we've ever had. But by the way, completely disproves all these theories. And we're going to kill it. Like we're going to voluntarily kill it because we're going to shut it down because we're going to go into these lockdowns and we're going to, yous. And basically, from an economic standpoint, the lockdowns, basically, it's a simultaneous killing of the demand side of the economy because you're telling people they
因此，在2020年1月，这简直是我们有生以来最好的经济，或许永远都是。它太棒了。然后，当然，新冠肺炎来了。对吧？完全正如你所说，就像我一样，你知道，像很多人一样，我刚开始被新冠肺炎吓坏了。部分原因是，天哪，我们将自愿地，你知道，我们将基本上把我们拥有过的最好的经济。但顺便说一句，这完全反驳了所有这些理论。我们要消灭它。就像我们要自愿消灭它一样，因为我们要关闭它，因为我们要进入这些封锁，我们要，你懂的。基本上，从经济的角度来看，封锁，基本上，这是对经济需求的同时扼杀，因为你告诉人们他们
have to stay home and they can't spend money. And it's a killing of the supply side of the economy, which is you're shutting down all the factories, all the production capabilities. And so I was like, basically, oh my God like Great Depression 2.0, like, you know, this is going to be a real problem. To your point, it turned out, right, well, part of what happened, obviously, was just like mass government subsidies, you know, a huge, you know, printing of trillions of dollars, and, and all these new social benefits, basically, we've been, we've been piloting UBI, at least in the US. And, and then, but yeah, look, part of what happened was basically all of these online
必须呆在家里，不能花钱。这是对经济供给侧的扼杀，也就是你要关闭所有的工厂、所有的生产能力。所以我当时想，天哪，就像大萧条2.0，你知道，这将是一个真正的问题。正如你所说，结果证明，对吧，好吧，发生的事情的一部分，很显然，就像政府的大规模补贴，你知道，巨额的，你知道，印了数万亿美元，而且，所有这些新的社会福利，基本上，我们一直在，我们一直在试行全民基本收入（UBI），至少在美国是这样。然后，但是，是的，看，发生的事情的一部分基本上是所有这些在线
forms of activity basically got shoved forward by, you know, I think as much as a decade, right. And so all of a sudden, you have this massive share shift, you know, from, you know, offline, you know, from retail stores that literally could not be open. All of a sudden, ecommerce, you have this massive share shift from school to online, you know, kind of physical classroom to online education, you have this massive share shift from school to online, you know, kind of physical classroom to online education. You have this massive share shift from commercial office space to teleconferencing. And, yeah, the consequences of the true long term consequences of this period may have much less to do with the health issues. It may have much more to do with the economic transformation, but this is really accelerated. And do you think let's let's talk a little about the politics, go back to the politics.
形式的活动基本上被向前推进了，你知道，我想至少十年，对吧。所以突然之间，你有了这种巨大的份额转移，你知道，从，你知道，离线下，你知道，来自 literalmente 无法营业的零售店。突然之间，电子商务，你有了这种从学校到在线的巨大份额转移，你知道，从实体教室到在线教育，你有了这种从学校到在线的巨大份额转移，你知道，从实体教室到在线教育。你有了这种从商业办公空间到电话会议的巨大份额转移。是的，这个时期的后果，真正的长期后果可能与健康问题关系不大。它可能与经济转型关系更大，但这确实加速了。你认为，让我们稍微谈谈政治，回到政治上来。
So there's always a sense that Silicon Valley and the digital revolution, all these things, I mean, precisely because they are moving the focus away from, you know, factories, organized labor, all those kinds of things that they are a force for kind of libertarianism and sort of anti-state, you know, that their tech companies don't want governments interfering with them. They sort of create that sense that you're the agent, you know, you're not, you know, you sitting in front of the screen, you're the master of your own destiny and so on. Do you think that's true? Do you think in the future, as we move more online and as tech plays a bigger and bigger role in our lives that we will become more libertarian and we will become in a sense more well i mean a silly way of referring to it but more right wing in that way
所以人们总有一种感觉，硅谷和数字革命，所有这些事情，我的意思是，正因为它们将焦点从工厂、有组织劳动力等事情上转移开，它们是某种自由主义和反国家主义的力量，你知道，他们的科技公司不希望政府干涉他们。他们创造了一种感觉，即你是代理人，你知道，你不是，你知道，你坐在屏幕前，你是自己命运的主人，等等。你觉得这是真的吗？你认为在未来，随着我们越来越多地转向线上，科技在我们的生活中扮演越来越重要的角色，我们会变得更加自由主义，我们在某种程度上会变得更加，我的意思是，一种愚蠢的指代方式，但在那种意义上会更加右翼。
yeah so i'll start by saying is there's a certain truth to the theory and and that certain truth is you know there is a libertarian wing to the tech industry um and there has been for a very long time um you know in in our time it's been, you know, kind of around, you know, this, uh, my, you know, my friend Peter Thiel, um, has become, you know, kind of one of these, one of these great, uh, one of these great American characters, um, you know, who's just an absolute genius and it's very inspirational for a lot of people, but as you know, is sort of famously a libertarian and kind of has a, has a culture that kind of orbits around him, uh, of libertarianism. Um, and so, you know, there is, there is that, uh, you know, there is there is that, you know,
是的，所以我要说的是，这个理论有一定道理，而那个一定道理是，你知道，科技行业里有一个自由主义派别，而且存在了很长时间，你知道，在我们的时代，它一直是，你知道，某种程度上围绕着，你知道，这个，我的，我的朋友彼得·蒂尔（Peter Thiel），嗯，已经成为，你知道，某种程度上这些伟大的，这些伟大的美国人物之一，嗯，你知道的，他绝对是个天才，对很多人来说非常励志，但正如你所知，他是个众所周知的自由主义者，并且有一种围绕着他的文化，自由主义的文化。所以，你知道，有，有那个，你知道，有那个，你知道，
there is that component. Just in reality, though, basically, like that's a it's a fringe of the politics of the Valley, at least the American tech industry. Overwhelmingly, the American tech industry is sort of what you just call classic, just progressive liberal. Right. And you can see you can see this, by the way, very clearly in the numbers, you can see this in the voting patterns in the Bay Area and you can see it in the political donations, like you take the typical big tech company or any cluster of people in Silicon Valley, you think the entrepreneurs would be the same way or the venture capital firms would be the same way
有那个组成部分。不过，现实中，基本上，那是山谷政治的边缘，至少是美国科技行业。绝大多数美国科技行业可以说是你刚才所说的经典、纯粹的进步自由派。对。你可以看到，顺便说一句，在数字中非常清楚地看到这一点，你可以在湾区的投票模式中看到这一点，你可以在政治捐款中看到这一点，比如你拿典型的科技大公司或硅谷的任何一群人来说，你认为企业家也会这样，或者风险投资公司也会这样。
you know, it's like during the 2016 cycle, it's like, you know, whatever 97% of the money or something went to, you know, went to Hillary Clinton right, and like, you know 0.0001% went to donald trump and donald trump but donald trump is not on twitter anymore um right exactly right exactly well you know so like yeah so uh you know trump that was not libertarian but like you know it is it is no you know for all of the national youth around you know
你知道，就像在2016年周期中，就像，你知道，不管97%的钱或类似的东西给了，你知道，给了希拉里·克林顿，对吧，就像，你知道0.0001%给了唐纳德·特朗普，唐纳德·特朗普，但唐纳德·特朗普不在推特上了，嗯，对吧，完全对，完全对，好吧，你知道，所以就像，是的，所以，嗯，你知道，特朗普那不是自由主义的，但像，你知道，它不是，你知道，尽管围绕着你所知道的所有国家青年
the tech industry and trump like you know peter was the only you know tech donor uh to donald trump like he was you know n of one um so Like he was, you know, end of one. So, but, you know, then look, there's like a little scattering, you know, you'll see a little scattering of money to Rand Paul or something or to whatever the Libertarian candidate was in 2016. But it's really on the margin. It's almost entirely the standard liberal progressive Democrat. And I think the reason for that, it's a very prosaic explanation, which is kind of almost too boring to talk about, which is just the tech industry is composed of people who are
科技行业和特朗普，像，你知道，彼得是唯一的，你知道，科技捐赠者，给唐纳德·特朗普，像他是，你知道，N分之一，所以，就像他是，你知道，N分之一。所以，但是，你知道，然后看，有一点零星的，你会看到给兰德·保罗（Rand Paul）或2016年任何自由党候选人的零星资金。但这真的只是在边缘。几乎完全是标准的自由进步派民主党人。我认为原因在于，这是一个非常平庸的解释，几乎无聊得不值得谈论，也就是科技行业由以下人员组成：
kind of almost too boring to talk about, which is just the tech industry is composed of people who are kind of highly educated. You know, they're highly open, and they're very socially progressive, you know, exactly, exactly as you'd expect from any sort of elite knowledge industry in the modern era. And they have the, they have overwhelmingly the exact politics of their peers in the entertainment industry or in the finance industry or in any of these other sort of knowledge work industries, um you know architects and graphic designers and it's all the same so it's it's overwhelmingly standard leftism um and i don't i don't really see any signs that um uh i don't really if anything that that's intensifying um if anything the the value is going for the left i mean i wonder if it's even more fundamental than that i mean you were talking about, you know, books, how amazing it
几乎无聊得不值得谈论，也就是科技行业由以下人员组成：他们受过高等教育。你知道，他们非常开放，他们在社会上非常进步，你知道，完全，完全正如你在现代任何精英知识行业中所期望的那样。他们拥有与他们在娱乐业、金融业或任何其他知识工作行业的同龄人完全相同的政治观点，你知道，建筑师和平面设计师，全都是一样的，所以它绝大多数是标准的左翼主义，而且我看不出有任何迹象表明，嗯，我真的不认为这种情况在加剧，如果有的话，价值观正在走向左翼。我的意思是，我想知道它是否比这更根本？我的意思是，你刚才谈到，你知道，书本，对于第一次读一本书来说是多么不可思议。在柏拉图的对话录中有一个著名的段落，他描述了埃及神透特（Thoth）来到法老面前说，看，我发明了文字。而法老完全惊呆了。这会产生毁灭性的影响。我们不会有的。很明显，你知道，柏拉图基本上同意这一点，因为柏拉图是一个巨大的保守派，尽管当然，是他把它写下来的。这种感觉不是存在吗，
would have been for the first time to read a book. And there's a famous passage in one of Plato's dialogues where he describes the Egyptian god Thoth coming to the pharaoh and saying, look, I've invented writing. And pharaoh is absolutely appalled. This is going to have a devastating effect. We're not going to have it. And it's evident that, you know, that Plato basically kind of agrees with this because Plato is a massive conservative, even though, of course, he's writing it down. And there is a sense, isn't there,
你知道，在每一次充满痉挛的变革时期，总有一些人的本能是说，这太糟糕了。这会变得更糟。为什么事情不能保持原样？然后还有其他人说，是的，这太不可信了。这有惊人的机会。我猜，我的意思是，看看你对此所写的，你绝对是一个认为，是的，这很棒的人。你在90年代的梦想，
that, you know, in every great convulsive period of change, there are people whose instinct is to say, this is going to be terrible. This is going to be for the worst. Why can't things just stay the way they are? And then there are others who say, yes, this is incredible. This has amazing opportunities. And I would guess, I mean, you're looking at what you've written about it, that you're absolutely someone who thinks, yes, this is great. Your dreams in the 90s,
我想，基本上已经实现了，不是吗？是的。所以，看，我想说的是，最重要的是，我几年前曾与安迪·格鲁夫（Andy Grove）过一次这样的对话，他在谈到新科技的影响时，在某种程度上，他只是把这个话题挥之而去。我当时想，我简直不敢相信你不是，你知道，我当时想，我简直不敢相信你对这个不感兴趣。就像，你知道，你，你是那个芯片专家。像你一定，你一定思考过这些后果。他基本上说，他说，看，这就像一旦新科技到来，就像，
I guess, have pretty much been fulfilled, haven't they? Yeah. So look, I guess I'd say more than anything else, I had this conversation with Andy Grove once years ago and he's, you know, talking about the impacts of new technology. And he's, to a certain extent, he just kind of waved the topic away. And I was like, I can't believe you're not, you know, I was like, I can't believe you're not more interested in this. Like, you know, you're the, you're the chip guy. Like you must, you must think about the consequences of these. And he basically said, he's like, look, it's like once new technology arrives, like, it's like,
你知道，就像，你知道，而不是写作或像钢铁一样，有一天我们没有钢铁。第二天我们有了钢铁。对。或者顺便说一句，有一天我们没有核武器。第二天我们有了核武器。主要发生的事情是，好吧，它来了。对。在某种程度上，这些争论其实并没有用，或者至少他认为它们没有用。因为就像，它来了。它不是，它不是，你永远不会倒退。就像你永远不会把精灵放回瓶子里一样。所以，你知道，这就像，这就像空气一样，现在你有空气了，恭喜你
you know, it's like, you know, instead of writing or like steel, like one day we don't have steel. The next day we have steel. Right. Or by the way, one day we don't have nuclear weapons. The next day we have nuclear weapons. Like the primary thing that happens is, okay, it's here. Right. Like to some extent, these debates are actually not useful, or at least he viewed them as not useful. Cause it's like, it's here. It's not, it's not, you're never going backwards. Like you're never putting the genie back in the bottle. And so, you know it's just it's just like it's just like air now you have air congratulations
对，就像每个人都要呼吸一样，没有争论，它就会发生，对。所以，你知道，在某种程度上，它只是简单地像，你知道，这项技术一旦人们弄清楚了，你知道，什么样的可能是可能的，然后他们构建它，你就不会把它放回瓶子里。现在，你知道，如果你不是一个工程师，你知道，这听起来有点疯狂。这听起来有点像工程师们认为他们只是在自动驾驶仪上。他们应该只建造他们想建造的任何东西。他们不承担更多对任何事情的责任。你知道，我，我，我对此最大的反驳是，我认为工程师在预测他们的新技术的消极和积极后果方面有着糟糕的记录。你知道，
right like everybody's gonna breathe there's no debate like it's just going to happen right um and so you know there's an extent to which it's just simply like you know this this technology once once people figure out you know kind of what's possible and they build it you you don't put it back in the bottle now you know if you're not an engineer you know that sounds a little bit insane it makes it sounds a little bit like engineers kind of what's possible and they build it. You don't put it back in the bottle. Now, you know, if you're not an engineer, you know, that sounds a little bit insane. It makes it sounds a little bit like engineers kind of think that they're just kind of on autopilot. They should just build whatever they want. They don't bear more responsibility for anything. You know, my, my, my big counter argument to that would be, I think engineers have a terrible track record of predicting both the negative and the positive consequences of their new technologies. You know,
我最喜欢的例子就是托马斯·爱迪生。托马斯·爱迪生，你知道，托马斯·爱迪生发明了留声机，嗯，你知道他完全确信，作为一个恰当的，你知道的，敬畏上帝的、他这一代人迷失的追求，他完全确信留声机的杀手级应用将是加强，你知道的，现有的宗教，因为人们终于可以拥有自己的家庭布道录音库，就在蜡质唱片上，当然对他来说，这是世界上最自然的事情，你在工厂辛苦工作了一天，晚上回家吃晚饭，然后你放上一段布道，你会说全家人坐在一起听布道，对，嗯，结果证明人们想要这个，结果证明他们想要这个非常邪恶的魔鬼音乐，叫
my favorite example of that was Thomas Edison.ison uh you know thomas edison invented the phonograph um and uh you know he was completely convinced as a proper you know god-fearing lost pursuit of his generation he was completely convinced that the killer app for the phonograph was going to be to reinforce you know existing religions because you would people would finally be able to have their own home libraries of sermons right on wax records and of course to him it was the most natural thing in the world you put in a hard day's work factory um you come home at night you'd have dinner and then you'd put on a sermon and you'd say the family was sitting around listening to the sermon right um and so it turns out people want that it turns out they wanted this you know very evil devil music called
爵士乐，对，所以，你知道，技术人员有，我不知道技术人员是否有任何真正的预测后果的记录。我不认为，我不知道非技术人员是否有很好的，你知道的，预测新科技后果的记录。你知道，科技是，按其本质，它只是一种工具。它是，你知道，人类决定如何使用一切。从来没有人能够弄清楚如何把任何东西放回盒子里。然后我认为，你知道，看，对于那些真正大的，我认为你有好有坏，对吧？我认为你有好有坏。我总是想到核武器，对吧？就像，你知道，核武器，就像所有的科技一样，
jazz uh right so so you know the technologists have a know, I don't know that the technologists have any sort of real track record for predicting consequences. I don't think, I don't know that the non-technologists have a very good, you know, record of predicting the consequences of new technology. You know, technology is, you know, by the very nature, it is just a tool. It is, you know, human beings who decide how to use everything. Nobody's ever been able to figure out how to put anything back in the box. And then I think, you know, look, with the really big ones, I think you've got good and bad, right? I think you've got the good and bad. I always think about nuclear weapons, right? It's like, you know, nuclear weapons, like of all the technologies,
你可能会想，也许我们作为一个物种不应该建造它，也许核武器就是那样东西。但就像，也许，你知道，我们现在已经75年了。而且，你知道，我们没有发生第三次世界大战。而且，你知道，也许它的存在现在在里面，你知道，我们没有发生第三次世界大战，嗯，你知道，也许核武器的存在意味着在20世纪70年代等常规第三次世界大战中死去的十亿人，你知道，没有死，所以也许也许他们实际上一直维持着和平，所以，是的，关于第三次世界大战的话题，我能问你关于中国的事吗？当然，中国是否已经将自己从硅谷解放出来了？它对互联网的控制使其能够
you think maybe we should not have built as a species, maybe nuclear weapons would be that thing. But it's like, maybe, you know, we're what, 75 years in now. And, you know, we haven't had World War Three. And, you know, maybe the existence of in now and you know we haven't had world war iii um and you know maybe the existence of nuclear weapons it means that a billion people who would have died in world in a conventional world war iii in the 1970s or something you know didn't didn't die um and so maybe maybe they've actually kept the peace this whole time and so you know yeah on the topic of world war iii could i just ask you about china sure and has has china kind of emancipated itself from basically silicon valley has it has its control of the internet enabled it to
摆脱这一点，这是否是对我们在西方的基于硅谷的互联网的威胁？嗯，我认为有两部分，我们可以谈论其中任何一部分。一个是实际的中国科技行业，它在多大程度上能够独立于美国运作，另一个问题是，我认为你问的更多的是关于伟大的防火墙，以及中国驾驭互联网和限制其影响的能力，我想还有利用互联网攻击西方，因为，你知道，你不需要核武器
to stand clear of that and and is that is that a threat to the the silicon valley based internet that we have in the west well i think there's two two part two parts of that we can we can talk about either one so one is just like the actual chinese tech industry and to what extent is it able to function kind of independently of the us um and then the other question is like um that i think you're asking is more around the great firewall um and sort of the chinese ability to kind of harness the internet and restrict its impact and i suppose also to to um to use the internet to attack the West because, you know, you don't need nuclear weapons
如果你能用黑客或任何东西来，不，但为了禁用，我不知道，美国发电厂。我的意思是，那是科技使之成为可能的事情，而这在40年前根本是不可能的。是的，确实如此。所以存在这样一个概念，即有时你会听到以网络为中心的战争这个词，网络上发生非正规战争
if you can use hackers or whatever to, no, but to kind of disable, I don't know, power stations in the US. I mean, that would be something that tech has made possible in a way that simply wouldn't have been possible kind of 40 years ago. Yeah, that's true. So there is this concept that sort of you know sometimes you're the term network-centric warfare kind of you know irregular warfare happening online
嗯，你知道，这确实是，我跟华盛顿的人谈过这件事，嗯，你知道，有所谓的战争学说，对吧？所以有军事规划人员，对吧，在任何大国都有关于什么算作军事袭击，什么算作战争行为的所有这些理论。你知道，什么是，你知道，会有什么报复？就像，如果，你知道，如果他们击落了我们的一架喷气式战斗机，我们该怎么办？对。在什么节点上他们会去？它不会从一场小规模冲突演变成一场战争，以此类推，一直导致并包括核打击。截至目前，据我所知，对于你可能称之为在线战争的东西，还没有战争学说。对。所以，你知道，俄罗斯人黑客攻击这个，中国人黑客攻击
um you know there there is this this is something i do i've talked to people in washington about um you know there there's you know there's there's so-called you know doctrine doctrines of war right so there's you know military planners right in any big country have all these theories about basically what counts as a military attack what what counts as a act of war. You know, what are you know, what retaliations happen? Like if, you know, if, you know, if, you know, if they shoot down one of our jet fighters, what do we do? Right. And at what point do they go? It doesn't go from, you know, kind of a skirmish to a war and so forth, you know, leading all the way up to and including, you know, nuclear nuclear strikes. As of right now, to my knowledge, there's no doctrine of war for what you might call online warfare. Right. And so, you know, the Russians hack this, the Chinese hack
那个，这个，那个，别的东西，你知道，不管怎样，国税局记录、投票机、发电厂、医院，你知道，所有这些勒索软件攻击背后是谁，你知道，它们是从哪里发起的，你知道，有人在试用那些，等等。至少现在，我有一种感觉，这是一个非常模糊的话题，因为DC没有人能回答我关于X、Y和Z在网上发生的问题，因此它导致了现实世界的军事报复。就像，这种学说实际上并不存在。现在，我会，我会把这归入更一般的非正规战争概念中，也就是基本上
that, this, that, the other thing, you know, whatever, you know, IRS records, voting machines, power plants, hospitals, you know, who's behind all these ransomware attacks, you know, where they've been launched from, you know, somebody, you know, trialing those, you know, and so forth and so on. And at least right now, I get the sense that that's, this is a very fuzzy topic, in the sense that like, it was, nobody in DC has been able to answer the question for me of X, Y, and Z happen online, and it therefore results in real world military retaliation. Like that, that doctrine literally doesn't exist. Now, I would, I would just, I would bucket this in with just this more general concept of irregular warfare um which is basically right
某种非传统战争，旨在基本上，你知道，所以在过去的日子里，那会像，你知道，破坏活动，作为一个例子。现在，我心中的乐观主义者基本上说，如果我们正在争论非正规战争，我们的情况相当不错，因为你宁愿坐在那里担心非正规战争，也不愿担心常规战争。所以我认为这可能意味着我们做得还不错。好吧，公平地说，但什么，这是一个问题，一个稍微奇怪的问题。所以显然在这个播客中，大多数时候我们回顾过去，我有点意识到我们使用这种新技术的大多数事情都是我们在20世纪80年代预测会使用的事情。所以，你知道，你从电脑屏幕上买东西，
sort of non-traditional warfare um you know aimed at basically you know you know so in the old days it would have been like you know sabotage right as an example um now the optimist in me basically says if we're arguing about irregular warfare we're in pretty good shape right because you'd much rather sit around and worry about irregular warfare than regular warfare so i i think probably this means we're doing okay okay fair enough but what um here's a here's a question a slightly odd question so obviously in this podcast most of the time we look backwards um and i'm sort of conscious that most of the things that we use this new technology for are things that we kind of predicted we'd use it for back in the 1980s. So, you know, you buy things from your computer screen,
你和朋友交谈，交流想法，在线阅读报纸。我的意思是，人们在1975年或1980年就说我们有一天会这样做。不过，接下来会是什么？我的意思是，我们还没有预见到什么，或者像我和汤姆这样不懂技术的人还没有预见到什么？你认为我们要去哪里
you talk to your friends, you exchange ideas, you read the newspaper online. I mean, people were saying we would do that one day, you know, in 1975 or 1980. What's coming, though? I mean, what's next that we haven't foreseen or that people like me and Tom, who don, what's next that we haven't foreseen or that people like me and Tom who don't know anything about technology haven't foreseen? Where do you think we're going
用这个？是的。所以一直让我一次又一次感到惊讶的事情，这就是我目前正在花大量时间试图在我们的日常工作中弄清楚的事情，互联网作为运动的推动者和催化剂，对吧？就像社会运动一样，对吧？我甚至可以说，正确的术语可能是邪教。对。我们在政治对话中稍微谈到了这一点。但我只想更笼统地说。
with this? Yeah. So the thing that just keeps surprising me over and over again, and this is where I'm trying to spend a lot of time trying to figure this out right now in our day job, it's the internet as an enabler and a catalyst for movements, right? Like social movements, right? And I would go so far as to say probably the right term is cults. Right. And we talked about this a little bit with the politics conversation. But I would just say more in general.
你只是看到，我经常感到震惊的事情。我忘了那边的新闻多不多，但是，你知道，关于GameStop（游戏驿站）的整件事，以及大约六个月前发生的这种大的股市风波。你知道，基本上，这群来自Reddit的随机家伙聚在一起，基本上把这些对冲基金痛宰了一顿。就像，你现在看到的基本上是这些不可思议的运动。我的意思是，你提到了“觉醒”（Woke）。觉醒是其中另一个，对吧？觉醒就像一个非常强大、充满活力的互联网运动。QAnon（匿名者Q）。QAnon也是其中一部分。
You just see, it's just that the things I've just been shocked by routinely. I forget if the press is much over there, but, you know, this whole thing with GameStop and, you know, this this big stock market kind of thing that happened like six months ago. You know, we're basically this this this basically crew of like random people on Reddit got together and basically just creamed a lot of these hedge funds. Like, you know, what you just see now basically is like these just, you know, these incredible movements. Well, I mean, you mentioned Woke. Like Woke is another one of these, right? Woke is this like very powerful, energized internet movement. QAnon. QAnon would be part of that as well.
是的，完全如此。所以QAnon。QAnon。QAnon。所以有这样一个概念，在游戏行业存在了很多年，叫做增强现实游戏，ARG。它的理念是，你拥有的游戏基本上是在虚拟环境和现实世界的混合中进行。多年来，人们建造过这样的ARG，就像，基本上就像，
Yeah, exactly. So QAnon. QAnon. QAnon. So there's this, there's this, there's this, there's been this concept in the gaming industry for many years called the augmented reality game, ARG. And it's this idea that you'll have games that basically play out in a hybrid of like basically a virtual environment, but also in the real world. And there have been these like ARGs over the years that people have built where it's like, basically it's like, you know,
有一个游戏，你基本上扮演一个间谍，下午三点你在办公桌上接到一个电话，你得去拿，不管是什么秘密包裹，这个那个，这个那个。然后有一些你需要解密的秘密电子邮件，等等。所以他们试图让你沉浸在这种半虚拟半真实的幻想中。所以ARG从未成为主流。没有人能够找出让这些东西真正起作用的公式，相比于仅仅是一个视频游戏。用技术术语来说，QAnon是第一个大规模的ARG。
there's this one game where you basically get to be a spy and like, you know, you get, you get a call at your desk at three in the afternoon and you have to go, you know, pick up, you know, whatever the secret package is, this and that, this and that. And then there's secret emails you have to decrypt and so forth. And so they try to kind of immerse you in this kind of fantasy, half virtual, half real kind of fantasy. So the ARGs never went mainstream. Nobody ever was able to figure out the formula to actually have these things take as compared to just a video game. In technical terms, QAnon is the first mass ARG.
对。对。就像有人在运行这个东西。他们现在的理论是它是谁，但就像有人在运行这个东西。而且，它，完全正如你所说。就像一个在线现象， literalmente 蹦出来了，现在你看到它出现在每一个，基本上，你知道，有某种政治集会等等，你在某些
Right. Right. Like somebody's running this thing. And their theories now is who it is, but like somebody's running this thing. And it, you know, quite literally, it's your point. Like it's an online phenomenon that literally like, you know, jumped out and now you see it present at every, you know, basically, you know, there's certain kinds of political rallies and so forth where you're in certain
国家的某些地方，它非常引人注目。所以，是的，不，那是一个，你知道，有某种政治集会等等，你在国家的某些地方，它非常引人注目。所以，是的，那是一个很好的例子。而且我认为，是的，我认为它是，你知道，也许就是这个。我的意思是，如果你想变得有点伪深刻，你知道，看，你可以说，看，现代西方文化、资本主义等等，对吧，标准的批评是它把人原子化了，消除了人们对家庭、部族、社会或文化的历史联系，你知道，可能是人们一直在寻找意义，传统宗教正在崩溃，所以人们的生活中存在着意义的真空，如果你想要意义，你
places in the country where it's just, it's very prominent. And so, yeah, no, that, that's a, that, you know, there's certain kinds of political rallies and so forth where you're in certain places in the country where it's just it's very prominent. And so, yeah, that's a that's a great example. And I think, yeah, I think it's, you know, it's maybe it's this. I mean, if you wanted to get kind of really pseudo profound, you know, look, you could kind of say, look, you know, kind of modern, you know, Western culture, capitalism capitalism so forth right the standard critique is it kind of you know atomized you know kind of you know eliminated a lot of the historic connections that people feel to kind of family or tribe right or society or culture um and you know it may be that the you know people have been basically looking for meaning you know traditional religion has been collapsing and so people there's this meaning void in people's lives and like if you want meaning you
几乎肯定能在网上的某个地方找到它。是的，我的意思是，我一点也不觉得那是伪深刻。我认为这正是正在发生的事情，人们找到了社群、凝聚力、目标感、谁站在你这一边、你需要恨谁的感知。我的意思是，他们在网上得到了所有这些，不是吗？是的，我想是的。我认为这种情况越来越多。我们实际上在商业中看到了这一点。我想说，我只举个例子。
can almost certainly find it somewhere online yeah i mean i don't think that's that's pseudo profound at all i think that's pseudo-profound at all. I think that's exactly what's happening, that people find community, cohesion, a sense of purpose, a sense of who's on your side, who you need to hate. I mean, they get all that online, don't they? Yeah, I think so. I think increasingly that's the case. We're actually seeing it in business. I would say that, like, I'll just give you an example.
你知道，加密货币，比特币，我说比特币是一场运动，对吧？这里有这样一个。好吧，我只举个例子。就像最近有这样一次尝试，你知道，华盛顿一直试图弄清楚该如何处理所有这些东西。
You know, cryptocurrency, Bitcoin, you know, I say Bitcoin is a movement, right? And there's just like this. Well, I'll just give you an example. Like there was just this, there's this attempt recently, you know, Washington's trying to figure out what to do with all this stuff all the time.
所以他们把这个比特币，基本上是立法附加到这个东西上，无论他们正在做的这个大的基础设施方案是什么。然后美国所有的比特币爱好者发生了一场大规模起义，对吧。所以我们就像，等一下，你不能那样做。这是我们的东西。你不能把它拿走。或者特斯拉，我认为这是另一个这样的故事，就像，特斯拉是一家汽车公司，还是拯救地球的全球科学运动？
So they attach this Bitcoin, basically legislation to this, whatever this big infrastructure package they're doing. And then there was this mass uprising of all of the Bitcoin aficionados, right, in the US. So we're like,, wait a minute, you can't do that. This is our thing. You can't take it away. Or Tesla, I think, is another one of these stories where it's like, is Tesla a car company or is it a global science movement to save the planet?
你参与这场运动的方式是关注埃隆·马斯克，倾听他的每一句话，宣扬他的福音，然后，顺便说一句，你买车，买股票。特斯拉，我不知道现在是不是这样，但不久前曾有一段时间，特斯拉股票的价值超过了全球其他所有汽车公司的总和。为什么会这样？嗯，也许是因为特斯拉将成为有史以来最好的汽车公司，这当然是可能的，但也许只是因为人们买它的股票不仅仅是因为他们喜欢公司的财务状况，也许是
Where the way that you participate in the movement is you follow Elon Musk, you hang on his every word, and you proselytize his gospel, and then, by the way, you buy the car and you buy the stock. And Tesla, I don't know if this is still the case, but there was a point not that long ago when Tesla stock was worth more than every other global car company combined. And why would that be? Well, maybe it's because Tesla is going to just be the best car know car company of all time which is certainly possible but maybe it's just because like people aren't just buying at stock because they like the financials the company maybe it's
成为运动的一部分，顺便说一句，也许这成了一个自我实现的预言，对吧，也许埃隆拥有如此强大的运动这一事实，福特背后没有运动，100年前亨利·福特是一场运动的领导者，但今天的福特汽车公司没有运动，丰田没有运动，但像特斯拉，有运动。苹果仍然是一种我正要说的运动，苹果，我的意思是可口可乐、李维斯或麦当劳，特别是在东欧什么的，我的意思是它们是政治意义和其他东西的象征，是的，但苹果，我的意思是它在90年代差点倒闭，不是吗？然后它有点像一个不断扩张的帝国，
part of being the movement um and by the way maybe that becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy right maybe the fact that elon has such a movement you know there's no movement behind ford right there there used to be like 100 years ago henry ford was leader of a movement but like for motor company today there's no movement in toyota there's no movement but like tesla there's a movement so apple remains the kind of movement i was about to say apple i mean cola or levi's or mcdonald's especially in the you know the eastern block or something i mean they were but they were signifiers of of of political meaning and stuff yeah but but but apple i mean it was it it it almost died in the 90s, didn't it? And then it kind of, like a kind of expanding empire,
它恢复了，吞并了音乐、电影、电视、手机和一切。我的意思是，我会说那是经典的例子。这就是为什么，它仍然是世界上最大的公司吗？我的意思是，曾经是，似乎是。是的，我的意思是。它是。顺便说一句，那个家伙，你知道史蒂夫从山上下了山，手里拿着平板电脑，是的，他确实，嗯，我想这可能是，平板电脑会告诉你到底该相信什么，是的，再买一个苹果产品通常是它所说的，嗯，我认为这是结束的完美音符，非常感谢你，这太棒了，正如多米尼克所说，
it recovered and annexed music and film and TV and phones and everything. And I mean, I would say that's the kind of the classic example. And that's why it's, is it still the largest company in the world? I mean, it was, seems to be. Yeah, I mean. It is. And by the way, the world i mean it was it seems to be yeah i mean it is and by the way the guy the guy you know steve came down from the mountain with the tablet yeah he did well i think that's probably and the tablet will tell you exactly what to believe yeah yeah buy another apple product is generally what it's what it's saying um i think that's the perfect note on which to end um can't thank you enough for this um it's been a blast and it's kind of you know as dominic says
通常我们花时间回顾过去，但展望未来也非常充满活力，所以其余的都是未来，谢谢你们，非常感谢，非常感谢大家收听。再见。感谢收听《其余的都是历史》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听加长版节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册，也就是目前这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
normally we spend the time um looking backwards but it's been very energizing to look forwards as well so the rest is the future thank you guys thanks very much thank you very much thanks everyone for listening. Bye bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com that's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通常我们花时间回顾过去，但展望未来也非常振奋人心，所以这就是未来，谢谢你们，非常感谢，非常感谢，谢谢大家的收听。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com，目前本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。